we're going to begin in Washington where
your esteemed elected officials are
flirting with financial catastrophe for
millions of Americans unless a deal can
be reached to raise the debt ceiling
President Biden and speaker Kevin
McCarthy have until June 1st to get
there but there is still a lot of ground
to cover between now and then the
president of course returned early from
an overseas trip last night in order to
continue these talks and our Nancy
Cordes is out the White House is at the
White House for us this morning good
morning Nancy tell us where do things
stand right now
well Tony good morning the good news is
that President Biden and speaker
McCarthy are set to meet again today
after a tumultuous weekend of on-again
off-again talks and negotiators did work
all weekend long but I have to tell you
the reports we have gotten about those
meetings have not been encouraging at
one point Republicans even insisted that
the talks were going backwards
President Biden returned to the White
House Sunday night he talked to speaker
McCarthy by phone on the way home from
Japan
[Applause]
but it did not sound like much has
changed but I've been very clear to him
from the very
big spend last year Republicans are
demanding deep spending cuts in exchange
for raising the nation's borrowing limit
which Congress must do in the next 10
days or so or risk the government
defaulting on its debts I propose cuts
and spending of over a trillion dollars
but I believe we have to also look at
the tax revenues sources say the White
House is now offering to keep spending
flat from this year to next Republicans
they say want to increase defense
spending while cutting everything else
by up to 22 percent of what they've
already proposed is simply uh quite
frankly unacceptable economists warned
that default could put millions of
Americans out of work and push the
country into a recession Social Security
checks could be delayed and the nation's
credit rating could be lowered it's the
risk of the downgrade that we've got to
worry about which is why it's incredibly
time sensitive with talks between white
house and Republican negotiators
faltering some Democrats are now urging
the president to exercise his authority
under the 14th Amendment and raise the
debt ceiling on his own without Congress
but it's an untested constitutional
maneuver the treasury secretary poured
cold water on it this weekend it doesn't
seem like something that could be
appropriately used in these
circumstances given the legal
uncertainty around it
secretary Yellen also reiterated that
early June remains a hard deadline she
does not think the U.S is going to be
able to pay all of its bills after that
which means that the treasury Department
would have to start making some tough
choices about who gets reimbursed and
who doesn't veterans benefits federal
worker pay and tax refunds could all be
on the line Gail
yeah let's hope they work this out thank
you very much Nancy